I think you mentioned in the context of
a social democracy that freedom of
speech and freedom of the press
or basically the freedom of people to
have a voice is an important component
which I think is something that caught
my ear a little bit because if you think
about the Soviet Union one of the ways
uh that the authoritarian regime is able
to control
it's almost part of the central planning
is you have to control the message and
you have to limit the freedom of the
press so there's a kind of notion
especially in like
ideas or maybe caricatures of the ideas
of cultural Marxism
sometimes caricatured even further as
wokism that you want to be careful the
speech with speech you want the sense of
speech because some speech hurts people
uh so in some sense you want to respect
the value the equality of human beings
by being careful with the words you say
so what is there attention there for you
I think there's no tension and in part I
think that it is very condescending or
patronizing for to assume that people
can't take debate that people can't
um either as a society or individuals
visually be
um engaged in the exchange of ideas
um without or even very vigorous debate
without
um you know being broken by it it's just
not the case
I'm basically a free speech absolutist I
mean I would draw the line it obviously
um direct incitements of violence or
certain other
um speech like that but in general you
think a lot of people would be surprised
to hear that
no I mean not not people who know my
work I mean more generally I think a lot
of people on the right
um even in the center I think might have
the idea that a lot of the far left
wants to censor them I think some of the
center left won't censor them but I
think a lot on on the far left on the
the Marxist or socialist left I think
that
um you know free speech is
um more or less the the norm yeah where
is the the imperative descents are
coming from is this just some small
subset of the left on Twitter is there
some philosophical idea behind certain
groups that like if we're to steal me on
the case and which group actually has uh
the the interests of humanity in mind uh
in wanting to censor speech I think we
might need to just take it Case by case
for an example by example because
honestly I
I I would have to think about a
particular case but let's just say
generally that a lot of American
liberalism
rightly sees the
um revolution around the Civil Rights
and later the extension of this writes
Revolution for gay rights and and so on
as being
um a very positive achievement of the
last half century and I completely agree
now for me
now that we've won those rights a lot of
our Battle For Change needs to go beyond
the representational realm and needs to
really reground itself in the material
bread and butter struggles of ordinary
people trying to survive uh the the
battle for uh good health care for all
Americans and so on these are my
immediate demands I think there's a
segment of American liberalism that
doesn't want to go in that
confrontational economic Direction and
wants to skirt away from battles over
things like Universal Health Care and so
on and really are just still caught at
this battle over rights representation
and it's devolved in such a way that
they feel like they need to make change
the way they make change is only through
interventions and culture because they
don't really have the same sense of
class and class struggle that agree or
disagree with it it's a very material
plane so instead you know they look at
committee Indians who said the wrong
thing or they look at
um you know all sorts of other ways to
make change it's not really making a
change it's just making them look bad
and making our culture worse and
um I think that's where a lot of it
comes from but I I think that a lot of
uh the left even the left that's much
more into battles over
um you know race and lots of other stuff
like real serious anti-anti racist on
the left of course I'm an anti-racist
but a lot of my my work is focused on
the Primacy of class but even these
people are very concerned about material
struggles and issues and they don't
really care about you know these issues
they think are
um ephemeral kind of issues so when you
focus
exclusively on language that somehow
leads you astray like on being concerned
about language without a
um like deeper economic inequalities and
so on you you just become an [ __ ]
that's on Twitter pointing out how
everything
how how racist that woman is so the
anti-racism becomes a caricature of
anti-racism exactly because anti-racism
was really about the struggle of people
for equal rights and voting it was about
the struggle for people who were trapped
into you know bad neighborhoods because
they were they couldn't get decent jobs
in their neighborhoods or redlined or
whatever else it was really like a
struggle for survival and what was the
main uh demands like the language of
this one it was the the March for for
jobs and freedom it was the slogan I am
a man you know asserting the kind of
universal Dignity of of people this is
what the Civil Rights Movement was was
about and it wasn't surprised there was
a lot of self-described socialists
people like Baird Russian Bayard Rustin
hey Phil Randolph uh Martin Luther King
Jr
I mean these were people who who were
Ella Baker they were socialists you know
and and
um I think a lot of Americans agree with
them with their immediate demands even
though they weren't themselves uh
socialist but it was a very
materialistic struggle and I think a lot
of this has been co-opted into just some
sort of vague and you know just
disconcerting complaints about language
or or culture and so on uh Martin Luther
King was a socialist to a degree was he
a socialist I I would love to learn
about that Martin Luther King I think
broadly called himself at various points
his life a Christian socialist or a
Democratic
um socialist especially after his
um speech against the Vietnam war in the
Riverside Church I think that was 67 the
last years of his life he became much
more involved in struggles against the
war and also struggles
um for workers rights you know he was
assassin when he was at a rally at
workers ride so he thought the next
battle was going to be an economic
battle he had this famous line where he
said
I don't just want to integrate the lunch
counter if it means that we can't afford
to order a burger while we're there you
know that was the line along those lines
and I think that got to his point where
the Civil Rights struggle was part of a
of a step of building some sort of wider
movement so he and these other civil
rights leaders were very much interested
in working with organized labor working
with
um you know the left as it was
constructed then and building some sort
of mass space for not just rights but
redistribution
it's fascinating it's fascinating which
figures self-identified and were in part
socialists Albert Einstein was one
Albert Einstein Albert Einstein wrote an
article for the first issue of this
um
left-wing
um magazines actually still publishing
today called monthly review and I think
1949 and his his article is called by
socialism I don't think it's paywalled
so so people should should check it out
but yeah Einstein was one huh
huh